[Music]
hey you guys it's sunday yeah and uh
this is a good one man this is a good
movie i liked it and i'm not really big
on the new godzilla movies
like did we okay did we see
the
this uh cause i didn't even realize this
is this is the fourth movie in the in
the monster verse that legendary is
doing so there was godzilla which came
out in what 2014 yeah
something like that did we did we watch
that yeah i kind of feel it i kind of
feel like we watched it anyway i think
the other one's called god godzilla king
of the monsters we saw that when it
wasn't yeah monsters we saw that one in
them well it was okay so it was godzilla
and then it was
uh kong skull island that was 2017 and
then godzilla king of the monsters i was
just in 2019
yeah i wanted to count in kong though
because i liked kong i liked kong better
than the two than the two uh godzilla
movies i didn't love king of the
monsters i liked like a lot of the
monster action and stuff but i thought
it was too long and i thought that there
was too much with the humans and like no
one cares about the humans
which i think is really the best part
about this movie yeah because it seems
like adam wingard directed this um you
know he started out in horror movies he
did your next which is actually a really
good uh kind of survival horror
if you haven't seen it
um and i think that he really seemed to
take like a lot of the criticisms of
king of the monsters to heart where it's
just like no one gives a [ __ ] about
these [ __ ] human characters can we
just see the monsters beating the crap
out of each other please and uh yeah you
you do actually get that
see
how about you guys i grew up watching
the old godzilla movies when i was a kid
and
those movies had a lot of [ __ ] filler
in it and the filler were the humans you
were just waiting to get rid of the
[ __ ]
humans out of the story so you could see
godzilla [ __ ] some [ __ ]
i want to see him [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up some models yeah you didn't
really you weren't buying into the into
this that this was a [ __ ]
huge creature to me it always looked
like a dude in a suit yeah moving in
slow motion crushing models and i liked
it because of that
because i wanted to crush some models
too i wish i was there
knocking the big [ __ ] buildings over
and [ __ ] grabbing the damn jets and
breaking them and [ __ ] you know i just i
thought that was cool because they look
like like a dude in a suit destroying
toys
yeah and you know when you're a little
boy you're like yeah break that [ __ ]
fire and stuff
i [ __ ] loved it
so when they came out with these
it's kind of like they tried to now in
the old godzilla movies a lot of there's
a lot of times you had to wait halfway
through the [ __ ] movie before you saw
them before you even saw the monster
yeah yeah yeah so the newer ones are
better in that regard yeah so what they
did was with this is they're like okay
we're gonna give the audience finally
what they want just [ __ ] monsters
fighting through the whole [ __ ] movie
you have human characters in there but
it's not you're not focused on those and
the story doesn't focus that much on
them
they're all like kind of like the humans
are just plot devices so you can show
more monsters and that's exactly the way
this shit's supposed to go
it's all spectacle yeah there's story
but you know what i mean it's a physical
story
who's throwing who and who's almost
getting whose head's almost getting
[ __ ]
destroyed by the [ __ ] i don't wanna i
don't wanna [ __ ] you know um sabotage
the movie or you know because it's still
new i don't wanna there are some
surprises in it
so
yeah because i wanted to say that it's
like all i'll say because i think
somebody already said in the uh comments
like what but it's not just
godzilla and king kong there's there's
another monster in here too and i was
very excited about it and i thought
there was going to be
a fourth one but it didn't happen maybe
next time it'll happen yeah they're
definitely gonna probably make another
because i think that this movie actually
ended up well it's i think this was
supposed to come out back in like in the
end of 2020 but then it kept getting
pushed back and then finally they
released it in theaters and then they
release it on hbo max at the same time
like in march uh hbo max i think had it
for a month and then it went to other
platforms so we actually saw it what did
we see it on amazon prime yeah it was
only like six bucks yeah we right it was
like five night five night yeah for the
for the hd so now it's time to rent it i
wasn't gonna pay 20 bucks for it first
they wanted i think spent 20 something
bucks and you could own it yeah but if i
was gonna pay that amount of money i
want it on blu-ray
yeah you want like the physical media
medium
and then it dropped down and now it's
down to six bucks so now it's at a good
rental
price and i think it came with some
extras but i don't think we watched them
maybe no maybe not because i thought it
was an hd and an hd plus i i don't know
we just yeah there's two different
versions because there was like a 4k
ultra and it's like we didn't we don't
have a 4k tv so it's like doesn't really
make any difference right but i mean i
definitely do think this is definitely
one that's probably gonna be better in a
theater because it's like so big and
like so epic but you know we didn't see
it in the theater yeah so
i mean but it was still good like our
big because the visuals in this are
super cool i really liked another thing
that i didn't like about king of the
monsters was that a lot of the monster
fights i've won there wasn't enough
monster fighting uh two all the monster
fights that took place in king of the
monsters were like in the dark kinda you
couldn't really see much and you
couldn't really see what was going on
this one there was like a bunch of
fights and a lot of them were in the
daytime i think my favorite favorite
sequence in this is when kong and
godzilla are fighting in hong kong and
you have all that [ __ ] neon like all
the neon lights it looks like a [ __ ]
vaporwave video that was [ __ ] awesome
i loved that yeah yeah it's got an
excellent visual style throughout the
entire movie um
there's also some wild [ __ ] here you
know what i mean [ __ ] that's paying
homage to some classic i guess i'll
spoil it journey to the center of the
earth yeah kind of [ __ ] yeah you see the
japanese had to make make up all these
kind of hooky uh
hokey kind of explanations of why there
are giant monsters and where the [ __ ]
are they going it so they were like well
it's on monster island
you know yeah and they're pissed off
because of radiation
that shit's not going to fly nowadays
not in a time with [ __ ] you know
google earth and every [ __ ] inch of
the earth is being covered by satellites
no it won't fly
so they go back to the old german
[ __ ]
germanic
sci-fi
like [ __ ] vril the coming power where
there is a hollow earth and there there
is a [ __ ] when you get to hollow
earth you they will show you hollow
earth
it's wild it's got its own physics and
[ __ ]
which like i said but i love that this
movie yeah it was
into this crazy [ __ ] yeah it's just it
took like we said we know this is
ridiculous but it's just like this is
what everybody wants to see we just want
a fun adventure popcorn movie with
monsters beating the crap out of each
other [ __ ] hollow earth you know
there's just crazy [ __ ] and it's just
like it leaned into it and that's great
that's what everybody wanted right
nobody wants it to be and it's not like
wacky like you know it has some comic
relief i really like the guy that's not
wacky it's just crazy yeah i mean the
premise is crazy
but crazy but you're like okay all right
all right i see what you're doing okay i
i like it i like it
i respect the game yeah
yeah well
the whole idea of a [ __ ] giant
gorillas and giant lizards is crazy too
so
if you got that you gotta have a crazy
explanation
so they went back to the hollow earth so
they took so basically
you're talking about uh what was it land
of time forgot and the people at time
forgot it's like that yeah it's that
type of thing right which they got from
which like i appreciate that because i
really liked those type of movies where
they're going down at the center of the
earth and they're woo there's a whole
other
universe down there man yeah and i
thought that was a really good idea like
is it believable no but it's like big
giant lizards and big giant apes aren't
believable either so you might as well
just well you see that opens up the
whole
property the whole universe because now
there's potential for all kinds of
[ __ ] monsters to appear because they
show you all kinds of [ __ ] that's in in
the hollow earth a lot of bad [ __ ] yeah
it's like an explanation for where all
of this stuff is coming from it's like
how did we not notice where all these
big giant monsters are coming from
[Laughter]
and now you go oh okay yes
that's where they're coming all right
you're taking me to that place all right
yeah they give you a sneak peek of all
the crazy [ __ ] that's down there so you
know there's much worse that you haven't
seen yet
so
now you can make unlimited movies see
that's a great that's a great [ __ ]
plot yeah that was a really good idea
because now you can make move you can
make 30 of these [ __ ] movies yeah and
still have a reasonable how where are
these [ __ ] monsters
why have we never noticed that yeah
but habitat do these things [ __ ]
evolve in how you know don't they have
large food requirements it's all
explained yeah and that's just and it
was just like such an elegant solution
yeah like i said it's not completely
believable but like i said big huge
monsters
aren't believable either yes so just
have fun with it
and i and i liked that they did that
because i kind of felt like king of the
monsters
tried to be like a little bit too
serious yeah with it and i kind of feel
like a lot of original godzilla movies
tried to be like that too yeah they were
and another problem is is that king of
the monsters did things that the old
made mistakes that some of the old ones
made where you put or put or try to
manufacture human stars in the movie you
know what i mean like we're gonna have
raymond burr or mill was that raymond
we're gonna put stars in the dark
no no no no no the star is always
godzilla or it's always [ __ ] kong or
it's always [ __ ] king ghidorah it's
always the monsters that are the stars
yeah why why are we watching it we don't
need the humans in nope
nope the humans are just a plot mega
plot device to show you more monsters
and that's the job of these human
characters in here and yeah they got
some okay characters i mean
granted some [ __ ] happens there's an
evil chick in there who [ __ ] kong
[ __ ] her up eventually you know it
crushes her ass and you're like yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
but there's no deep connection to any of
these characters you don't give a [ __ ]
and they know you don't give a [ __ ] so
that i can show you a whole bunch of
them and there it is and it's a
fast-paced
movie that's fun to watch a lot of
visual stimulation great epic fights a
bunch of yeah that aircraft carrier oh
yeah that was great they were
they had kong
on a [ __ ] cargo ship strapped to the
to the top of it where the whole several
aircraft carriers and a whole bunch of
destroyers escorting his ass
across the ocean they got him knocked
out he's pissed off he's wanting to go
back and want to go home and [ __ ]
[ __ ] godzilla attack
godzilla
and he's they're standing on the ships
as if they're the size of like canoes
jumping from one ship to the next
sinking ships like his ship's going it's
[ __ ] badass
and that's in the beginning of the moon
yeah that's like not too that's not too
far into the movie yeah and i like that
they cause i i feel like i and i guess
this may be started with sort of like
the mcu and stuff like that where they
feel like they have to make these big
epic movies which that's fine but now
everything has to be like three hours
long
i like that this movie
is not even two hours long yeah so they
didn't even so it doesn't have to be two
hours and 20 minutes it doesn't happen
so it's like like i said they do have
some stuff with the characters i like
the addition of uh the little girl uh
from
i guess she was from skull island or
whatever she was like one of the native
but she uh she was uh deaf right and she
communicated with kong through sign
language so i liked that even though
like when she first turned up you said
oh we have a kenny yeah
and then she did the job of a candy too
yeah she wasn't annoying like a kennedy
they they knew i think they'd been
watching brandon tennold about what a
candy was because they didn't do the
brandon kennel [ __ ] kenny mistakes
mango badger says this word the word out
that the word out there is that
legendary are making the next one and it
will have no humans involved
at all now see wouldn't that be just
monsters the whole way that you don't
need the humans yeah and like i said i
like this one because you know i like
some of the human characters i like um
you know what's her name uh millie bobby
brown 11. i want to call her yeah
yeah there's other guy like just called
her the stranger things chick but yeah
so she's in it she's cute she's only in
a few scenes i like the conspiracy
theory podcaster guy he was kind of like
the comic relief he was funny but they
didn't do they didn't overdo the human
characters you know what i mean and um i
kind of liked uh you know their little
side mission
because there's kind of like two
plots sort of going on at the same time
that sort of like interconnect but it's
not real complicated um you know like i
said it's it's kind of like you just
tune in to watch monsters beat the crap
out of each other beowulf says the
hollow earth kind of looked like the
films would uh journey to the center of
the earth and
earth and hollow earth's that the
brendan brendan frazier yeah
he was in those no he was in all those
mummy movies like in the 90s
he was an encino man that was probably
his breakout role
are those any good i don't know i
haven't seen them i like the old ones
like [ __ ] yeah the land that time
forgot and people that time forgot that
was good too
and that people at time forgot had tor
johnson in it and it was like some [ __ ]
out of a [ __ ] frankfurzetta
yeah satanic samurais and barbarians and
[ __ ] that's looking pretty cool
worshiping earth got a [ __ ] lava gods
yeah i like that one lava guys lava gods
yeah that sounds like a 90s sexual
tyrannosauruses yeah
godzilla is a sexual tyrannosaur he is
yeah
i mean i you know it's it's just this is
just a really really fun
you know it's like i don't even know
it's not super memorable or super deep
or anything like that but
i don't know i had a way better time
with it because honestly
i liked parts of king of the monsters
but a lot of that i thought was kind of
boring
um because like i didn't really care
about the humans this one i cared about
the humans a little bit more but they
really weren't you know there were they
didn't overdo the stuff with the humans
they kind of just kept it moving and um
you know and there was enough monster
action and the way i really like the way
that they kind of framed all the monster
action too like i said all the stuff
with the neon and all this you know it's
just it was it was done really well
just the way it was edited together and
you really got a sense of how big
these creatures were now i will say this
is actually because somebody said is
this like a straight up remake um in
case you guys didn't know there was a
king kong versus godzilla made back in
1962. i'd say no which uh no um well
adam wingard when he got this he
basically said well
he wanted to make something that was he
liked that movie but you know like i
said that's very cheesy it's two guys in
suits like pushing trees down each
other's throats and stuff and um but he
kind of wanted to do something like that
but he wanted to
kind of do something new with it like
taking little bits
of you know from the mythology of both
monsters and sort of putting it together
so there are kind of
you know and i don't really know
i'm not one of those people that's like
has seen every godzilla movie or every
kong movie so i'm not see everyone no
and it's like so i'm not super up on the
lore so there might have been like some
other stuff in the movie that
was like hey there was like an easter
egg or something like if you're really
into either one of those monsters like
or their shared universe so so i don't
know about that but i think this was
just like a really good and honestly i
don't even think you have to have seen
the other ones
no
really i saw the other ones that didn't
pay close attention to it yeah i really
wasn't impressed with the first godzilla
and i wasn't really impressed the king
of the monsters we saw it in the movie
theater
the only other one that i liked was kong
skull island and i would put this one
right there if not better than comic
school as kong skull island and i really
liked kong skull i did it as well i
thought that was super fun yeah and this
one's fun for the same reason yeah this
one's a lot like i would say
i'd have to see skull island again
but i enjoyed it just as much as i like
skull island the first time i saw it
i've only seen skull island once
it makes you want to buy all these on
blu-ray i'll wait a little bit till
prices come down maybe and maybe i'll
buy them i'd like to have them in the
collection i mean they're good movies
don't get me wrong all of them even the
even the one that i i liked least was
king of the monsters
and it was still pretty good it was
still good it just had
it just had too many humans in it too
many stories about him yeah i just
thought a lot of it could have been
trimmed out and it would have been a lot
better and i thought that the that the
monster fights should have been more
like impressive yeah um this one i
thought was really cool because it was a
lot of monster fights and they were in
different environments yeah and they
were well lit
so you could see what was happening
there's a whole
there's a whole um [ __ ] subculture
about studying godzilla movies yeah a
good one good got it to see on youtube
about this subject would be brandon
tennold he's done a lot of reviews on
all of them he's a big fan of all yeah
he's a humongous godzilla and they're
not all the same only so really the very
first one the black and white one was
the best one that was like a serious
film
yeah all right it was like a horror
movie it was pretty good
um
i also liked rodin i remember liking
that one um there was
there were some of them were kind of
like uh
monster fest where it had a bunch of
them but they tried to do this several
times throughout the entire run of the
movies touhou making them and some of
them were just reusing film
they were just yeah using clips and and
it was just padded out with a bunch of
garbage
they weren't all good
um now
some of the newer ones like i think it
was godzilla 1983 or 85 or 87 i don't
remember yeah because there's been
several i didn't even realize but there
have been several uh
reboots and like iterations of them even
going back to like the 70s and 80s they
hadn't made a godzilla move in a long
time and i was uh in high school and
they came out with a new godzilla movie
i think it was godzilla 1984 or 85 maybe
83 some [ __ ] like that and it was good
it was like the old ones
but more monsters more crushing models
and [ __ ] it was a good one
um
some of the [ __ ] wasn't that good you
know what i mean [ __ ] i wasn't big
into mothra that much um
i like the idea of mothra yeah you know
what i mean and the monster she looks
cool yeah
but
and i like i liked that mothra made an
appearance in king of the monsters like
because i always liked the look of that
of that monster yeah and then godzilla
there was a competitor from another
company and they did [ __ ] camera and
i liked gamma as a kid until you grow up
you grow up a little bit you watch gamer
again and gamer is for very little kids
it's [ __ ] oh yeah
and i didn't realize it was for
that young of an age group um
but teenagers could actually watch
a good godzilla movie
yeah i remembered godzilla in 1985 being
pretty good
and i was a teenager at the time maybe
you guys might remember the gamera
movies are like pretty funny though
because i kind of feel like they
i almost kind of feel like mst like gave
them a much wider audience like in the
us because they were kind of like
godzilla knockoffs
um you know so as cheap as some of the
old godzilla movies looked i mean the
camera ones look like they cost about
two bucks to make
like the monsters were just like stupid
and ridiculous badger says avoid
godzilla and the smog monster i saw that
when i was a kid i saw when i was a kid
and liked it but i think i took a look
at it later and it was like it was
terrible
but when you're a kid you don't know any
better you
your your your attention span isn't very
long and it was easy to amuse a kid back
in those days
i remember that that [ __ ] slime
monster and they're [ __ ]
killing all the fish and [ __ ]
killing people with [ __ ] smoke and
[ __ ] it was a pollution monster
yeah that's [ __ ] funny beowulf 18
says yeah brendan frazier's version of
journey to the center of the earth was
actually really good i never watched it
for the longest time thinking that it
sucked but
i gotta see it then i mean yeah see you
probably but i didn't even realize that
they had remade that with brenda fraser
like i said i i remember really liking
the mummy movies that he was in like in
the 90s um but i didn't know that they'd
done journey this night of theirs but i
you know i i kind of like that they went
that way with this one because like i
said it brings back that whole kind of
like old school like adventure movie
we've type of thing we've been watching
just just a word out to you guys i think
it's free on on um on amazon plus right
now i recommend them we saw the first
two hatchets hatchet one and hatchet too
we might do a matinee on them although i
might want there's two more i thought
there was only one
there's a hatchet three and then there's
one that's just called victor crowley
we're gonna do a review on those um if
not this week then next week yeah
they're good if you like the old
if you like old classic
friday the 13th stuff it homage is
friday the 13th the demage is all kind
of cane hotter isn't it it's got a lot
of famous people in it um yeah there's a
lot of little horror easter eggs and
stuff taking place down in uh
in louisiana in the bayou he's like a
[ __ ]
he's like a cajun
he's basically
a [ __ ] cajun
jason yeah it's good cajun jason yeah
jason that's pretty funny they empty him
up it looks like he's on roids and his
[ __ ] face is [ __ ] up kind of like
the [ __ ] well what's his old tad from
[ __ ]
car from from from fun house yeah yeah
it's pretty badass
mega said i would recommend checking out
gorgo the 60s british godzilla
i've seen it a bunch of times i saw it
on mystery science theater actually
that's a really good mystery science
theater episode yeah it's like it's it's
like godzilla but in ireland yeah um you
know it's pretty amazing yeah they had a
[ __ ] danish one or swedish one that
was [ __ ] terrible too remember that
reptilicus reptilicus that was also yeah
that was danish wasn't it that was also
one that was on the new mystery science
later
danish or swedish or something
didn't know what's not the one that had
that really weird like differently abled
guy in there that like stuck his hand in
a in a tank full of eels or something
i have to like see that again tammy says
yes do a hatchet review i saw them
already yeah so we definitely will i do
want to watch the other two because you
know we were just watching we didn't go
out last night because we went out
friday night because we were tired so we
were just like watching a bu we watched
a [ __ ] ton of movies last night
because i wanted to like get caught up
because i was like oh we can have like
we can watch all the movies for the
matinees like all like in one night so
we watch like four or five movies in a
row and two of them were hatchet and
hatchet too and i so i want to see if
they have the other two on amazon prime
for free guys asking if the tom cruise
money is any good uh jenny's gonna say
no i didn't know i didn't love it i'm
gonna say yes i liked it i didn't like
it i liked it but you have to understand
the reason why jenny didn't like is
jenny is in the classic gothic horror
and she didn't like people [ __ ]
around with their universal monsters
like [ __ ] frankenstein and i don't
like making horror movies into action
movies that just pisses me off in that
one they took
all the universal classic monsters and
they turned it into an action movie
kind of like [ __ ] uh uh
kind of like kind of like what you see
here or nah
now would be
i put it up there with like uh
what's the werewolf and vampire one for
underworld
yeah which i didn't like underworld
either kind of like underwear van
helsing or something i didn't like any
of those it was like a mixture of
underworld and the extraordinary league
of gentlemen yeah except it was about
monsters and uh tom cruise is a generic
action
hero tom cruise plays himself as a whole
as usual through the whole [ __ ] movie
that's part of the that's the part of
the charm of that movie is it's
it's pure cheese russell crowe plays uh
uh uh dr jekyll i loved it i [ __ ]
okay i liked that part yeah i would have
watched a whole movie about that guy
yeah but when he started going mr hive
he'd go to mr hire slowly and she'd he'd
start [ __ ] talking and he'd start
getting more and more aggressive and
more and more [ __ ] evil and i'm just
like getting sucked in going yeah yeah
man yeah that's right
yes indeed let's do this [ __ ] you know i
mean
i like that one i also liked um
another good one that i i think a lot of
people don't talk about it that much
with venom i really liked venom i liked
venom as well yeah i want to get that
one on but that wasn't pretending that
was like a comic book movie but it was
like a monster movie too but it wasn't
like purporting to be oh hey we're gonna
remake like the universal like dark
universe except we're making it not
scary and now it's an action movie like
i was laughing because mark navarro said
mission impossible mommy protocol yeah
yeah yeah that's pretty much exactly
what yeah
that's exactly what it was like there's
something about it though man there's so
i i i like uh i like the mission
impossible ones especially
fallout fallout was a really well see i
liked that i liked that and uh there's
something about tom cruise playing
himself
because i know what's going on but get
out of my [ __ ] horror movie everybody
knows what's going on stay in your lane
everybody knows what's going on when tom
cruise has played himself he's supposed
to be playing himself kind of like the
way kind of kind of like the way [ __ ]
steven seagal plays himself
but you know he's not as bad as steven
seagal
[Laughter]
you're paying to see top crew tom cruise
he better be tom cruise that's what he's
doing
and uh i liked it and they had a uh
[ __ ] the mummy was a chick
and she was [ __ ] sexy
sexy sexy gothic [ __ ] bubby which i
don't i i'm not averse to like the sexy
mummy
angle and i actually liked the look of
the mummy yeah she looked great i just
felt like it was too much action movie
and not enough scary movie uh there
wasn't enough mummy in it
um and there should have been more mummy
and more jekyll and hyde and it should
have been darker and scarier and more
like a horror movie and not like that's
what they were going for i know but it's
obvious to me that with that one they
were going for a 10 10 pole
big tent pole
over the top american action movie yeah
like like the like the superhero movies
yeah like the mcu like with monsters
monsters but see nobody wanted to see
that because it's like that lost a [ __ ]
ton of money and they just said okay
[ __ ] it we're not doing anymore i think
a part of the problem was the way it was
yeah
the market wasn't there for it
but it wasn't a bad quality movie you
could see that [ __ ] for free
yeah and i liked it i liked it it's
because i wasn't expecting anything out
of it yeah i mean i didn't hate it i
just kind of like wish
i just wish that if they were gonna make
a movie like that like don't make it
don't make it like oh it's a universal
mummy movie except now it's an action
movie just like make an original
property yeah is you know then i
wouldn't have been mad at it well what
was funny is that it wasn't a mummy
movie
it was a mummy movie a [ __ ]
vampire movie
yeah it had a vampire did it yeah a
vampire movie was there i can't even
remember well didn't tom cruise become a
vampire
but did he i think he did
oh yeah
yeah wait did he become a vampire or a
mummy or uh i think it was no didn't he
become didn't become like a jekyll and
hyde but now see i can't even remember
what the [ __ ] happened to mommy movie it
was a dr jekyll movie it was a
frankenstein movie it was all the
monsters all the monsters in it and i
thought i thought they were insinuating
that tom cruise was turned into a
vampire at the end
which would be funny and now they could
go back and like mash it up with
interview with the paper
so it'll be like a crossover universal
and writing i actually kind of want to
see it again share the universe
people people [ __ ] piss on that movie
i actually want to see it again
like i said i didn't hate it i just wish
that it
that they would have like just made it
its own thing instead of trying to be
like hey it's like the mommy like the
universal monster movie what they should
have done is bitten off less
and made it about one thing yeah
yeah it was a little scatter shot i will
say that what they tried to do is they
tried to do like what they did with the
mcu and just like put the make it like
the avengers we're making a big stew
whatever we're throwing everybody in
that's what that might have been the
problem yeah
yeah that was a big problem it was very
unfocused that was another thing
like other than it just being if i was
in the theater and i was [ __ ]
tripping balls i would [ __ ] love that
movie even more
they had some [ __ ] ridiculous special
effects when when the mummy busted out
big old [ __ ] clouds of [ __ ] smoke
[ __ ] shaped like skulls were going
everywhere everything big explosions the
mummy was making explosions that were
flattening old blocks yeah it was
ridiculous
that's not like there's something creepy
about that there's nothing scary about
that
it's just yeah tammy said it sounds like
they try to do a version of penny
dreadful i wish it had been more like
penny dreadful because i actually quite
like penny dried folks yeah somebody had
mentioned something else in here that i
wanted to say something about
about
kaiju or about big monsters or anything
like that it was
monster verse that's what they're
calling this you know the shared kong
and
yeah it's fine yeah they did they did
they did a good job with it
yeah this one i like like i said they've
all been good but i think this is
probably
i think this is probably the best of the
ones that i've seen although skull
island was really good too but i mean
this one i think i like this one a
little bit better because also there was
godzilla and godzilla was badass and i
like i said i loved that [ __ ] yeah
big huge epic fight in hong kong
kong liked the league of extraordinary
gentlemen if you like that one which i
liked that one it needed to there needed
to be more to it but i like i like that
i remember not liking that but i haven't
seen it in a long time if if you like
that one you'd like the tom cruise mommy
because it's a similar vibe similar vibe
but i think better
better like i said it just reminded me
unpleasantly of
you know those 90s
uh action horror movies like van helsing
and underworld and stuff like that which
i was not really a fan of right like
just these over-the-top like special
effects spectacle type and they're not
scary or anything like that which i
don't know that just like made me mad so
it just like reminded me of that yeah
but talking about the uh the superheroes
i'm not a huge fan of them i didn't
really like the mcu um
i i really liked that first venom i
think it should have been r-rated it
should have been scarier like some other
alien i think it would have made even
more money
and they got a new one coming out it
looks a little harder and i think that'd
be really cool because when that when
that venom [ __ ] monster was like i
want to roll you want to bite off your
heads and roll them like little turds
i was i wanted to go yeah yeah let's see
that
that's how i could see that but it's
like don't don't tease us like yeah
maybe tease me
i wanted this thing that we wanted to
turn into [ __ ] yeah i wanted it to do
some evil [ __ ] to let me know that yeah
this thing's [ __ ] bad you know
and then uh like
a superhero movie that i liked
that evidently some of these mcu
puritans didn't like was i liked shazam
i liked the tone of shazam i thought
shazam was really [ __ ]
well they're making another one of those
too yeah that was a really fun well i
kind of felt like a lot of people like
that because that's dc right but it's
like they you know they just leaned into
like the you know just the ridiculous
and funness of the premise and i think
they did a good job little kids turned
into adults
adult superheroes i thought that was a
[ __ ] great idea yeah i really liked
it and uh and how what what how a little
kid would be tripping out and he wasn't
that little he was a teenager how that
teenager would be tripping out some
people were like yeah but
he acted younger as an adult than he did
when he was when he was a kid and he
said man you're reading too much into
this [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ]
comic book movie you know
but i would like yeah black adam that's
gonna have to rock
yeah that's yeah it's supposed to yeah
yeah and i think that's related to the
to the chamber verse
[Laughter]
yeah but i like that yeah dc's hit and
miss this somebody was saying that
there's a new uh suicide squad it's like
yeah i just i just saw a trailer for it
earlier it's a part two for the suicide
i didn't see the first one
yeah we saw um birds of prey which i
actually quite liked it was video it's
you know it was okay
um but i don't think i saw the first
suicide squad did i but yeah so there's
a new one coming out i just like i just
saw the preview for it like about an
hour ago matter of fact i saw the a
different i saw that [ __ ]
superman
versus batman
i didn't it was just a um
well you know a lot of them are just
kind of like
spectacle movies like i said which like
you know they're enjoyable while you
watch them but i don't even remember i
mean i can't remember like which of the
mc mcu movies i've seen and which ones i
haven't which generally which i'm going
to go back to shazam i remember shazam
yeah i remembered everything well they
were doing something different yeah
yeah and he was like a good character
right like and his relationship with his
friend like after he turned into this
yeah i just really liked there was a lot
of heart to it i liked that another one
that surprised me out of the out of the
super hero genre that i i enjoyed it and
remembered it was into the spider verse
i didn't think i was gonna like that one
it was it was animated
that was great it was great i liked it
there was all these different kinds and
it made me want to see other ones like i
wanted to see
animated spider-man noir i wanted to see
a whole movie with spider-man noir yeah
and then it was like a japanese
spider-man who was a girl in a in a
mecca that looked like an anime girl in
a little round ball that had spider legs
on it that looked and she drove it
around that looked cool
there was a lot of stuff in yeah you
could expand that whole expand it thing
out like with the little pig and
everything the little pig
[Laughter]
and then there was the
bomb spiderman
[Laughter]
he's a drunk
loser spiderman
i just i thought it was a good idea
i kind of feel like that one did so well
because i think that even got nominated
for some oscars and stuff too so i mean
they might make another one of those and
then i think the central character was
named miles morales spider-man and he
was pretty good yeah he's pretty good
but i really wanted to see spider-man
noir
yeah that was that was pretty black and
white yeah that would be awesome yeah
but like i said there there does seem to
be um you know a lot a large audience
for
those types of movies
um it's just you never know
which one's going to hit what's which
one's going to miss it's like sometimes
i feel like i can't even believe like
all the [ __ ]
all of the
extended universe stuff i it blows my
mind how many mcu movies they've made
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't even realize
like until we started like watching them
at the theater and stuff and they were
just like no there's like three phases
and there's like 20
[ __ ] bajillion movies holy crap but
it's just kind of like everything how do
these people have time to make all these
movies goddamn yeah omega system people
calls right tom got infected by part of
the curse of the mum yeah yeah yeah he
was but i thought
i thought how it that that part of that
curse had turned him into a it looked
like a vampire
you know i mean which it's an undead
which is a mummy wasn't not dead well i
kind of felt that well i kind of feel
like i don't even think they were
talking about vampires but i do
definitely think that the mummy had
vampire qualities qualities to it so it
was almost kind of like a combined
vampire mummy sort of monster well that
that checks out with um
anne rice's
versions of what a vampire was yeah
that was like
egypt
no back in ancient egypt a poltergeist
outbreak happened in a royal family and
and it possessed somebody and murdered
the wife and the [ __ ] poltergeist
spirit went into the blood through the
[ __ ] through through the cuts and
animated the blood and it was possessed
blood which brought her back to life and
then she could give that blood to other
people and that
paranormal entity as a poltergeist could
inhabit more bodies it was like
possession
yeah and she was kind of a vampire or
not she was kind of like a mummy
and a vampire at the same time
so because they kind of had her sitting
like she was dead but she was just
frozen solid it was kind of a weird
murder merge between
a vampire and a mummy that's what i
thought that's what i saw
yeah they're doing a similar kind of
thing similar right
camp guy said my son's generation likes
the kick-ass movies i likes the kick-ass
the first one was the best one obviously
but what they need is they need a
r-rated
bernthal
punisher okay a movie
and you gotta get burnt all on i s i'm
watching it i watched part of the
television the new series the first
season i didn't like it i got partly
through the second season just lost
interest
he's get on cycle and [ __ ] pick up
about 20 pounds of muscle get really
[ __ ] mean and stop making
the punisher a good guy the punisher was
not really a good guy
punisher was a bad guy
that killed other bad guys all right
and like he was in season two of
daredevil that's really the way the
punishers should always be shown but
they're not gonna do that i don't think
because there's too many damn veterans
out there with head injuries and i don't
think they want to encourage
[ __ ] to go out there and just
start regulating
you know because that's what the
punisher's doing he's regulating
and uh they don't want that to happen i
guess but that's what that [ __ ] story
should be you never should soften that
character
he's a [ __ ] psychopath
you know connor watson says yeah like
dexter yeah and actually they're redoing
they're doing a new season at dexter
right great yeah um which i'm actually
excited about because i know people
really didn't like the way the series
ended i wasn't um i wasn't mad at it it
was it was fine yeah um i can see how it
probably pissed some people off but i'm
super excited no let's let it roll yeah
if it's written right
yeah i mean i love that guy i love you i
love michael c hall but um the only
portrayal of the punisher i will give my
[ __ ] tom ross seal of approval on
is season two
of the daredevil and bernthal [ __ ]
knocked it out apart because they
allowed him to be that character he was
so good in that role that now i can't
imagine anyone else playing the punisher
but him right he's he got a little
smaller
he needs to [ __ ] bulk up some because
the punisher was [ __ ] you looked at
the [ __ ] punish he was he was on
roids he was righted out
you know
um which that checks out special
operation guys and delta force guys they
did steroids you know if again hell yeah
and um but
that character is the type of dude just
as shown in season two he's the type of
dude to hang a bad guy from a meat hook
and torture him for information which is
that's what he did in that movie
yeah in that series and that's exactly
the kind of [ __ ] he would do
when i saw that i was just like oh [ __ ]
this is the punisher this is the [ __ ]
punisher and then he gets sent to prison
and [ __ ] kills everybody on the
[ __ ] tier with a shift
and a space i remember that scene yeah
like that's the punisher all right
and his superhero was his [ __ ] head
injury that's the [ __ ] punisher
his superpower is [ __ ] brain damage
brain damage brain damage yeah rick shaw
says dark man is the best superhero
movie
i really like dark man we should
probably do like a retrospective the
first one the second one wasn't quite as
good i don't remember if i saw the
second one yeah i feel like we should do
dark man we should also do
um
what was that movie called dark city
like the one about
oh you haven't seen that one like the
one with uh the the one kiefer
sutherland was in it and everyone like
goes to sleep and then like they
rearrange yeah i haven't seen it that's
a kick-ass movie i really like that
movie and i feel like it's a little bit
like underrated another good one was
robocop one robocop 2 was pretty good
too but robocop 3 went on
no but noble cop 1 was a masterpiece
did we have we even done a retrospective
on robocop we need to oh oh my god i
thought we had already done it robocop 1
was a [ __ ] masterpiece it [ __ ] was
a product of its time it was [ __ ]
insane
and corporate and [ __ ] insane and
[ __ ]
that was the 80s on lsd and steroids
that's exactly what that was all about
[ __ ] corporate insanity in detroit
and i lived in detroit that's exactly
the way it was
yeah yeah all right so we have anything
else that we need to discuss about
but yeah i was going to say uh godzilla
versus kong it made like a [ __ ] ton of
money even though a lot of the theaters
were shut down and stuff so they are
actually going to make it concept
robocop 2 is the best one yeah robocop 2
is good the same director that did
empire strikes back
robocop 2 i don't laugh at robocop 2 the
tongue was a little bit
not quite as insane as robocop and there
was something about robocop one of
seeing it for the first time the
introduction of that character had a lot
to do with that movie
that character being introduced and
seeing his limitations and seeing what
was going on that was a big part robocop
2 he'd already been introduced
so didn't quite have the same effect on
you
but yeah
robocop 2 was a great movie it was good
yeah i liked the second one yeah i mean
it was the first one's like a hard act
to follow it's hard to follow because
the bad guys uh the first one were so
good yeah clarence botticker and his
[ __ ] gang yeah who said that did
alfred hitchcock say that that it's like
you if you have a great villain you have
a great movie yeah
i think yeah kane was an okay villain
but it's hard to beat that [ __ ]
clarence bonaker and his [ __ ] gang of
[ __ ] thugs running around on [ __ ]
ninjas one dude running around on a damn
ninja with a mac 10
[ __ ] shooting the gasoline pumps and
[ __ ] blowing up and [ __ ] and it's
smoking yellow cigarettes that just
everything was taken to a [ __ ]
to a next level them cigarettes were
[ __ ]
yellow you guys didn't notice that
i was a kid going man that cigarettes
yellow they had some of those maybe they
were like european or something because
i have seen other movies like i've seen
some like giallo movies and stuff
there's an american yellow cigarette we
wanted a yellow cigarette let you know
there's extra nicotine extra tar
yeah that's what that is like super bad
for me super bad for you
yeah oh my god yeah yeah well you know
all right so we will be back tomorrow at
three o'clock eastern standard time
talking about
one of the movies that we watched
because like i said we watched a [ __ ]
ton of them last night
i don't know if we're gonna do hatchet
yet though because i wanna watch the
other two uh before we do because then i
can do all four of them at once but we
watched some other ones like some older
ones that we could talk about if we
don't get around to that so
everybody uh thanks everybody for
dropping by and have a good rest of your
weekend and all of that and we'll see
you guys tomorrow
bye